toujours en tendance et les gars ça va
ma chérie comme j'adore salue les
victoires
pour cette dernière soirée danse on
adore et à son remplaçant grâce à qui
cette colocation
ben est un truc de magal commence à y
bien plus à l'ouest un plan b est belle
à internet encore dispo jane manson
sinon t'es célibataire et aux huit ans
ces chiens et loups cinq ans maman n'est
aux normes
[ __ ] c'était quoi ça
[Musique]
je veux avoir des mannequins se
profilent des gamins c'est très simple
alors la semaine faisait plus la toile
tic et tac vous dégagez là tout va bien
quitter mon appartement appartement où
se trouve mon mari qui doit se trouve en
recommandant sandrine alors nous on
reste et toi tu m'en fous
et evans
là c'est la guitare on ne sort pas de
table avant d'avoir terminé son assiette
[Musique]
on
12 heures du matin là les enfants comme
c'est pas possible
250 euros pour tapage nocturne savoir
plus les escrocs là
bon tant mieux